je m'appelle karine balme je suis né le
29 avril 1939 à saumur dans le maine et
loire
mes études ont été très brève et en
étant donné que la 15 ans j'étais obligé
de travailler pour des raisons de
finance à 15 ans donc j'ai étudié la
comédie chez solange 6/4 puis j'ai
travaillé au théâtre des variétés avec
robert dhéry dans la revue jupons vol
j'ai continué dans différentes
différents théâtres j'étais au grand
guignol à la pièce de robert hossein
la chair de l'orchidée et puis je suis
parti en tournée j'ai monté un tour de
chant et je suis parti en tournée avec
ma soeur de deux ans et demi je suis
revenu à paris je suis reparti enfin
j'ai fait différentes choses je suis
allé beaucoup en italie c'est pour on a
raison la raison pour laquelle je
connais un petit peu l'italien je me
débrouille assez bien
vous m'avez demandé une petite phrase en
italien je vais vous la donner sur nos
stats initalia quattro médiéviste aux
roms à venezia l'italien mattia jim holt
haut var et au renard émard danse aussi
voilà je ne sais plus si ce que
maintenant les autres avec pourquoi
j'aimerais de speakerine et bien j'étais
speakerine heures en italie dans
différentes boîtes et et samassa masser
puis j'estime que c'est une que c'est
une une partie du métier qu'il faut
connaître je sais pas je crois que ça
peut amener beaucoup de choses
d'ailleurs une décontraction devant la
caméra une
enfin je crois que ça peut être
intéressant
de me revoir tous les autres visages
vers le projecteur qui est à votre
gauche de le regarder doucement on est
doucement de face dans la caméra
regardez maintenant à votre droite
encore un profil plus pour plus à droite
encore ont mené bien deux faces
doucement et le dernier sourire de la
faim et vous font des bien pensants
mesdames dans ses rangs une seconde s'il
vous plaît que je prenne met en
situation vous avez reçu en arrivant là
plus d'une heure un texte ce texte est
un texte les annonces d'une journée type
de télévision alors hulu demande de bien
vouloir respecter le plus possible les
horaires les noms des émissions et des
auteurs et réalisateurs de ceux ci à la
mesure du possible je vous permets
donner des petites difficultés qu'ont
les tout à l'heure que vous conserviez
votre papier pas loin de vous mais je
vous demande de le regarder le moins
souvent possible et particulièrement
nous adresser à la caméra on sait que
c'est la première annonce de la journée
de la présentatrice
alors maintenant attention à vous
bonjour mesdames bonjour mademoiselle
bonjour messieurs et bien notre
programme va débuter dans quelques
instants avec notre douzième épisode de
notre feuilleton mon ami flicka à 13h
notre journal télévisé vous sera
présenté par maurice ou werther nos
émissions reprendront à 18h45 avec
l'avenir est à vous une émission de
françoise dumas y est réalisé par jean
pierre chartier et jean-charles l'agneau
à 19h10 la voiture moderne une émission
de jean bardin et bernard hub rennes
consacre aujourd'hui à jean painlevé
nous pourrons voir notamment quelques
extraits de ses films et dont le célèbre
vampire à 19h40 notre feuilleton
quotidien grand prix le film de harry
keller à 20h notre journal télévisé sera
présentée par françois barnole à 20h30
nous partirons à aix en provence
nous pourrons assister au premier acte
d'idoménée roi de crète opéras de mozart
présenté par max pol fouchet et réalisé
par claude oursel à 21h10
nous reviendrons vers michel droit pour
son émission à propos qui nous permettra
d'entendre igor stravinsky parler de son
oeuvre et des problèmes de la musique de
la musique pop contemporaine pardon à
21h50 histoire de sourire une émission
de variétés de michel arnaud avec entre
autres guy bedos
la réalisation sera de jean christophe
averty à 22h35 nos émissions se
termineront par le journal télévisé qui
vous sera présenté par françois génot
bonne après midi ces dames ont 2 ce soir
dramatique la radiodiffusion télévision
française à l'honneur de vous présenter
l'île des chèvres pièce de l'auteur
italien ou gobetti qui sera interprété
non les auteurs je suis navré je sais
pas où gobetti qui a été avec kit avec
10 go fabre il obtient le plus en vue
cette pièce a été représenté à paris en
octobre 1953
l'interprétation sera la suivante silvia
monfort dans le rôle dans agathe à betty
schneider dans le rôle de sylvia bernard
v avec bernard verley
évidemment
mademoiselle l'interprète principale de
l'île des chèvres vient d'être prise
d'un malaise ou là pour eux non à
l'instant aussi ne sommes nous pas en
mesure de diffuser cette émission qui
était prévu en direct veuillez improvisé
une annonce d' excuses et indiqué qu'un
film policier intitulé le grand sommeil
avec une vraie bonne garde et lauren
bacall remplacera cette émission vous à
quelques secondes de réflexion fondé le
grand sommeil vous voyez le fondu
attention nous sommes absolument désolés
mais nous venons d'apprendre que silvia
monfort étant gravement malade
notre émission nous sommes dans la
possibilité de vous présenter notre
émission 1 place vous verrez un film
américain le grand sommeil avec un homme
frais bogarde et lauren bacall
nous espérons que vous passerez quand
même une très bonne soirée et l'émission
sera sûrement reporter dans le courant
des jours qui viennent rhodes moselle à
vouloir aller vers le piano donne à
votre droite vous appuyez appuyé à son
piano
vous convient pas en 40 ou même vers
nous un petit peu maintenant il ya un
fauteuil à votre gauche alors je vous
demander de bien vouloir vous y rendre
et de vous inscrire dans ce fauteuil est
le dernier sourire de la fin fondée et
coupé merci je m'appelle viviane
maillard j'ai 21 ans mes diplômes je
n'en ai pas à part mon certificat
d'études
ensuite quelques études d'années
d'études commerciales deux ans une année
et demie de cobra matic et sanctionné
par aucun diplôme
j'occupe en ce moment une fonction de
standardiste je ne parle aucune langue
étrangère et je désire être speakerine
parce que j'aime ce contact lointain
avec le public
et mon dieu c'est nouveau pour moi et la
télévision matière beaucoup très bien je
crois que le public vous l'entendez
d'habitude et maintenant celui qui
devrait vous entendre on vous êtes
gentils de tourner doucement votre
visage vers le projecteur est à votre
gauche
d'où ce manque encore un peu plus voilà
vous revenez de fasse doucement toujours
vers la caméra ou le tourner à droite au
visage maintenant encore un peu revenez
de face
je voudrais un sourire de décontracter
si possible ou el attaf et vous font des
coupes
bonsoir mesdames % et demoiselles
bonsoir messieurs voici l'ensemble des
émissions pour la journée du 24 octobre
tout d'abord à 12h30 notre feuilleton
mon ami flic a aujourd'hui douzième
épisode à 13h première émission du
journal télévisé présenté par maurice
werther ensuite à 18h45
l'avenir est à vous une émission de
françoise dit mme hayet réalisé par jeu
jean pierre chartier à 19h40 notre
feuilleton quotidien notre feuilleton
quotidien grand prix un film de 2 à rick
hallet à 20h deuxième émission du
journal télévisé à 20h30 en direct
d'aix-en-provence vous pourrez assister
au premier acte hideux mais des roi de
crète un opéra de wolfgang amadeus
mozart
présenté par max pol fouchet et réalisé
par claude l'on sait 21h10 à propos les
missions de mouches de michel droit vous
permettra d'entendre igor stravinsky
vous parler de son oeuvre et des
problèmes de la musique contemporaine
21h50 histoire de sourire de michel
arnaud avec guy bedos réalisation jean
christophe averty à 22h35 notre dernière
émission du journal télévisé présenté
par françois jeannin
bonsoir mesdames % les demoiselles
bonsoir messieurs ce soir dramatique la
radiodiffusion télévision française à
l'honneur de vous présenter un sombre
drame de l'acteur de l'auteur italia
hugo betty fortement déconseillé aux
enfants
cette pièce fut créée en 1953 au théâtre
du noctambule à paris hugo betty est
avec diego fabry un des auteurs italiens
les plus en vue
voici la distribution silvia monfort
sera agatha betty schneider sylvia
yvette etiévant pia et bernard verley
angèle l'eau nous apprenons à l'instant
même que l'interprète principale de
l'île des chèvres vient d'être prise
d'un malaise aussi ne sommes nous pas en
mesure de diffuser cette émission qui
était prévu en direct veuillez improvisé
une annonce d' excuses et indiqué qu'un
film policier intitulé le grand sommeil
avec humphrey bogart et lauren bacall
remplacera cette émission j'avais
quelques secondes pour y réfléchir
fondée en donner l'image
attention une et principe aux uns des
principaux interprètes de l'île des
chèvres étant souffrante
nous nous voyons dans l'impossibilité de
vous donner cette pièce de hugo betty
qui sera nous le regrettons remplacé par
le film policier grand sommeil avec une
très bonne garde et lauren bacall
nous nous excusons vivement on
bon là mademoiselle je vais vous
demander d'avoir la gentillesse d'aller
jusqu'aux piano quête à votre droite
d'une démarche qui vous conviendra aller
jusqu au piano et vous appuierez comme
vous voudrez ne plus détendu possible et
puis maintenant je vous demande et vous
voyez vous avez un fauteuil à votre
gauche de bien vouloir vous y rendre et
vous y asseoir
fondée groupe et merci aux modèles et
voilà à vous peut-être d'apporter qui
d'autres éclaircissements en tout cas ce
que votre imagination formeront au cours
de cette émission nous avons eu deux
interruptions de l'image dont nous vous
demandons de vouloir bien nous excuser
et maintenant vous savez qu'un 22h15
nous avons rendez vous avec les coureurs
du tour de france
le résumé films et de la 6e étape de ce
43ème tour de france mais en attendant
nous allons voir un petit film un film
de courts métrages jean jacques cornu
qui a pour titre la couronne de paris
cette petite promenade en avion n'était
pas désagréable
n'est ce pas cela nous a donné le goût
du voyage c'est pourquoi dans quelques
instants nous allons nous transporter
sur la route grâce aux images qui nous
sont envoyées par toute notre équipe de
reportage dirigé par jacques angibaud et
nous écouterons gens quitte à refaire
les commentaires de cette 6e étape du
tour de france
mais vous savez que cette émission est
retransmise en eurovision
c'est pourquoi c'est à 22h cases
précises que nous vous la proposons
on
l'indicatif que vous venez d'entendre
que vais devoir vous a rappelé que cette
émission du tour de france et transmises
en eurovision
vous pouvez le deviner sans entrer dans
les détails techniques il y à de
nombreuses commutation à faire et c'est
par suite d'une erreur de commutation
que vous n'avez pas entendu au début de
l'émission de ce soir
le commentaire de jean qui tarde ne vous
en toutes nos excuses et en particulier
à ceux d'entre vous qui s'intéressent
spécialement au tour de france nous
espérons que vous pourrez voir la
seconde diffusion qui sera donné demain
comme chaque jour à 12h30 encore nos
excuses et maintenant et maintenant nous
laissons tout à fait la bicyclette pour
parler livre avec pierre dumayet pierre
des groupes max pol fouchet et nicole v
dresde en lecture pour tous une
réalisation de jean prat
à
cette télévision qui demain vous
proposera à 12h30 une seconde diffusion
de la sixième étape du tour de france
tout au moins du résumé films et de la
6e étape du tour de france et ce sera
notre premier rendez vous de demain à
12h45 nous verrons téléparis à 13h15 la
troisième diffusion du journal le soir
pour nos jeunes amis à 19h30 will i am
magnin proposera son magazine pile ou
face à 20h toujours pour nos jeunes amis
et peut-être aussi pour les grands notre
feuilleton rabat à 20h15 le journal
télévisé à 20h40 un grand music hall
parade de gilles margaritis qui
s'achèvera à 21h50 pour faire place à
sport panorama c'est en effet l'équipe
roger benhamou pierre badel et étienne
d'un loup qui vous proposeront cette
émission et qui se terminera pour faire
place à nouveau au sport puisqu'il sera
l'ère du tour de france
22h15 enfin à 22h30 nous terminerons
avec de la musique puisque ce sera les
missions des grands interprètes
bernard gavoty recevra demain gérard
souzay dans une émission qui est réalisé
par jean-paul carey et nous terminons
tout à fait la soirée comme aujourd'hui
avec dernières heures et la seconde
diffusion du journal télévisé ces
nouvelles de dernière heure ce soir on
vous être donnée par claude joubert à
qui je donne maintenant la parole non
sans vous avoir dit bien sûr
bonsoir et bungie à demain
à l'occasion de la pose de la première
chers amis m'ont soir voici qu'elle sera
demain le programme de la deuxième
chaîne il débutera à 20h avec un nouvel
épisode du film de jean-jacques sirkis
laventure du ciel puis ce sera 20 heures
case la suite du feuilleton albéri car
la route est amateur 30 les actualités
télévisées à 20h50 vous retrouverez
roger moore dans le rôle du sein d'après
l'oeuvre de leslie charteris puis à
21h40 pierre de la garde et nancy galles
en vous présentant leurs émissions j'ai
d'oeuvre en péril et la soirée se
terminera à 22h10 paris l'édition
spéciale des actualités télévisées
bonsoir chers amis bonsoir voici qu'elle
sera demain le programme de la deuxième
chaîne
il débutera à 20h avec un nouvel épisode
du film de jean-jacques sirkis laventure
du ciel puis ce sera à 20h case la suite
du feuilleton d'albert écart l'arc et à
20h30 les actualités télévisées à 20h50
dans la série du côté de la musique vous
prévoir une émission de francis boucher
le temps d'une nuit où seront évoqués
des souvenirs de jazz puis à 21h va ce
sera un voyage en afrique et à 22h05
deux valises pour un massacre qui sera
une émission de la série de jean marc
école de filles il suffit de s'entendre
vous retrouverez claire et jean françois
et la soirée se terminera à 22h25 par
une édition spéciale les actualités
télévisées
bonsoir
bonsoir téléspectateurs de la deuxième
chaîne j'espère que vous avez pu
profiter des conseils de vos radios
électricien pour vérifier cet après midi
le réglage de vaud récepteur voici le
programme que vous pourrez recevoir ce
soir sur le canal 22 bande 4,625 ligne à
partir de 20h30
tout d'abord un film burlesque de court
métrage de la série félix de christian
duval ex
un quart d'heure plus tard une émission
de variétés de daniel labre réalisé par
jean charles l'agneau qui a pour titre
trois années trois succès ensuite de 21h
à 21h50 opéra croquis le petit musicien
d'après penney scénario et dialogues
pierre gillot et emile noël réalisation
jean marie coll de fille rendez vous si
vous le désirez à 20h30 sur la deuxième
chaîne ce soir au revoir et à tout à
l'heure
inviter les spectateurs bonsoir le
programme que vous pourrez suivre sur la
deuxième chaîne demain dimanche débutera
à 14 heures 45
par la suite de votre feuilleton
l'extravagante lui si ce feuilleton sera
suivie à 15h10 par un long métrage de
robert mais négoce intitulé la millième
fenêtres et dont les deux principaux
interprètes ont pour nom pierre freiner
et jean louis trintignant
ce programme d'après midi s'achèvera
donc à 16h10 pour reprendre en début de
soirée à 18 heures 30 heure à laquelle
vous sera proposé une émission de
bernard gavoty musique dans le monde en
quelque sorte un magazine international
de la musique
il vous sera ensuite proposé à 19h30 en
direct de la maison de rtf l'émission de
jeu de jean paul landau est les trois
masques animée par robert manuel
puis à 20h la suite du film de
jean-jacques sirkis laventure dans le
ciel consacré à l'histoire de l'aviation
et à 20h15 la suite du feuilleton la
route adapté du roman d'albert et cas à
20h30 bien sûr vous seront présentés et
nos actualités télévisées et tout de
suite après à 20h50 l'émission de roger
benhamou les 50 visage de l'amérique
sera consacrée demain à l'état du
maryland
les commentaires seront de georges de
caunes pour terminer la soirée à 22h10
vous retrouverez rod taylor qui
incarnera une fois de plus pour vous le
rôle de l'inspecteur glenn evans cela au
cours d'un court métrage policiers de la
série hong kong
intitulé à vous de jouer evans c'est
ainsi que s'achève ras le programme qui
vous sera proposé demain sur la deuxième
chaîne
bonsoir
amédée les spectateurs bonsoir le
programme que nous vous proposons de
regarder sur la deuxième chaîne demain
soir débutera à 20h par la suite du film
de jean-jacques sirkis laventure du ciel
consacrée à la petite histoire de
l'aviation
il vous sera ensuite proposé à 20h15 un
nouvel épisode de votre feuilleton la
route adapté du roman d'albert qu'un et
tout de suite après les actualités
télévisées de 20h30 et bien vous pourrez
suivre une émission de jeu de pierre
bellemare jean françois cap et jacques
rouland champions sera alors 20h50
havas des merveilles ensuite
exceptionnellement de m'asseoir robert
rocca vous présentera son émission
publique des 4 jeudis en direct depuis
londres le players théâtre participeront
également à cette émission
pierre tchernia robert dhéry et colette
brosset à 22h ensuite eh bien nous vous
proposerons de regarder rire au sourire
une émission de jacques vigoureux
consacrée au dessinateur humoristique et
de m'asseoir au cours de cette émission
eh bien vous ferez connaissance un peu
plus intimement avec le dessinateur
barberousse tout à fait en fin de
programme à 22h30 vous sera présenté
l'édition spéciale des actualités
télévisées
voilà c'est ainsi que s'achèvera le
programme qui vous sera proposé demain
soir sur la deuxième chaîne pour soir
amy téléspectateurs bonsoir le programme
que vous pourrez suivre sur la deuxième
chaîne demain lundi débutera à 20h par
la suite du film de jean-jacques sirkis
laventure du ciel ce film sera suivi à
20h15 d'un nouvel épisode du feuilleton
la route adapté du roman d'albert ica et
tout de suite après les actualités
télévisées de 20h30 et bien vous pourrez
suivre à partir de 20h50 dans la série
film dramatique
l'héritière un film de william ou l'air
adapté du roman d'henry james ce film
obtint en 1955
oscar pour terminer la soirée tout à
fait en fin de programme
une édition spéciale des actualités
télévisées vous sera présenté à 22h40
bonsoir